so a student athlete who said your dad
is also very athletic as well having
that athletes mentality does that give
you an advantage for still yank you um I
guess an in maybe you know III think um
I mean you know I started acting in
college like officially I mean I didn't
have really i think i was gonna play in
like kindergarten or something but we
none of my school's it out you know they
went to growing up anyway had any like
theater programs we almost put on a play
in think it was seventh grade and then
it didn't happen like you know and i was
supposed to be the lead and i'll never
forget that and but that's it none of
them had like I never did it in high
school I went to a technical school
which was like a vocational school and I
was an electrician and that's what I was
that's why I was gonna do you know like
I had offers for really high you know
from really big companies you know I 18
years old coming at high school to be an
electrician like I was I was really
skilled in that and the only other thing
I did do was play sports you know I was
I was a state scholar athlete through
high school and uh and i think if it
were to give me any advantage it would
have been just being in front of a crowd
you know in front of people um on a
stage in a way you know because I mean
as an athlete you know playing
basketball soccer or baseball I mean you
know you have people come and watch or
whatever so I kind of had that you know
I where you know you have to be able to
perform in front of watchful eyes you
know and performing obviously in a very
different way but still you know it I
think it sort of gave me that
opportunity to I guess just be under
pressure in a situation where people are
watching down on you know upon you but
um I don't know I think in terms of what
it brings for me what it did was it
really informs um I think my work as an
actor because you know everybody works
differently some people are more tuned
in you know on a mental note or
emotional you know um like I'm somebody
like and I get a script and and and and
i'm reading something like physically i
have to be able to relate to it you know
and by that I just mean like you know I
I do little things like you know I word
shoes or or you know try to think of
what I'm wearing and a lot of my talk
sometimes with like directors or other
people in working with it you know I
asked a lot of those types of questions
like you know what one might be wearing
or some of the times the people I want
to speak to first I like the customers
and this just to kind of understand so I
can just kind of get into that you know
mindset and that makes me feel that puts
me at a place I guess physically where
then i can let loose a little bit more
on a you know just the mental side of it
you know so um you know there's like the
famous I don't remember if it's olivier
feel like it's olivier dustin hoffman
but like there's this funny story of
like doesn't hoffman doing push-ups and
running around and you know they're
about do see where needs to be out of
breath you know and if it's olivier i
hope that that's i'm making the
recognition believe a was just like why
don't you just act you know it like
instead of just working yourself up just
use your imagination you know and I
don't think that personally I don't
think there is one way you know there
are tools that we each have their just
like you know all the acting schools and
teachers out there people that say oh
there's only one way to do it i don't i
don't personally believe in because I've
never I've never found any script or any
project that I can identify that only
one thing worked for that you know what
I mean like it's like you know people
that that do certain specific things you
know sir I think it's people that
they'll they'll speak about you did see
the Meissner or method where they say
well they can't play Greeks because if
you've never killed your own kid how can
you know how can you do that you know I
mean how can you relate to something
like that or some some classic material
you know and and I don't know I just
think there are tools for each thing
like I think you know you can use bits
and pieces of everything and so for me
physically I mean I still feel you have
to feel you know in a way like you know
feeling out of breath and yeah and
thinking like you're out of breath I've
had to do both where you I don't have
time to go do jumping jacks or anything
like that but I know how to breathe
heavy and make that you know feel um
like like a it's supposed to I guess
like it's intended but I do think
sometimes you know sometimes you just
need to take a lap around the building
before you go shoot a scene you know and
and and sometimes you just need to clear
your head and just just do it so I
you know for me the way I approach my
work from a physical standpoint first it
just works for me you know it works for
the type of movies that I do and want to
continue to do you know so I would say
that would maybe be the only advantage
it brings you know or those two things i
should say is just having been in front
of crowds from young age and then you
know just just feeling like you want to
feel a connection to it somebody I don't
know for me like one of my pet peeves
are watching like sports movies or
anything where people have to play
sports I'm like they can't even toss a
ball like you know that's a physical
thing you know like if you've never
pitched before or you've never thrown a
football like you need to learn how the
mechanics of that you know it needs to
look real you know because we can
identify and you don't have to be a
sports player to know that like this
person doesn't look like they know how
to throw a baseball you know tomato
shoot a basketball so I do think there
are times where physicality does play a
big factor you know and some of my
favorite actors are the the people who
are physical you know and take on
different physicalities when they're
doing their work so so that's that's to
me another reason why I feel like I
identify more with with that sort of
approach
you